the Trump administration is getting
ready to put its temporary travel ban in
place it will stop most visits from six
mainly Muslim countries for 90 days the
Supreme Court yesterday threw out lower
court orders blocking the ban the
president called it a quote great day
for America's future security and safety
Jan Crawford is outside the Supreme
Court Jan good morning
well good morning so you know president
Trump has been slapped down at every
turn by the appeals courts but the
justices get the last word in yesterday
they all agreed to allow at least part
of his travel ban so in the next few
days the government will stop denying
visas to certain travelers from those
six countries considered safe havens for
terrorism we will destroy radical
Islamic terrorism
president Trump reaffirmed his
commitment to national security during a
visit Monday by the Indian Prime
Minister except for that tweet steered
clear reacting to his administration's
victory thank you very much everybody
the inside opinion announced by Chief
Justice John Roberts said preserving
national security is an urgent objective
of the highest order it's a unanimous
rebuke to two federal appeals courts
that halted the ban nationwide after
those courts found it violated federal
law and amounted to unconstitutional
religious discrimination against Muslims
reaction from immigrants rights groups
was Swift this Muslim and Refugee ban is
unjust it is unamerican and we will
continue to fight it in the courts and
in the streets this is kind of a slap to
the face of Muslims around the country
and even around the world but the court
stops short of allowing the president's
full ban to take effect saying it would
not apply to immigrants who have a bona
fide relationship with a person or
entity in the United States such as a
close family member or a position at an
American company or university I think
it's premature to call this you know a
victory or a non victory Hawaii Turney
General Doug Chen who fought against the
ban called that provision a partial win
but said his state could still be
negatively affected anybody outside of
the United States who's watching
everything that's half
there's no question you know it this
that what has happened has has created a
chilling effect now the justices
scheduled arguments for October but the
administration had originally said it
needed this travel ban while it reviewed
immigration vetting procedures so by
then this whole case could be moot Gail
all right Jan thank you